دق يردام المواطن البريطاني الايراني علي
رضا اكبر مسمارا اخر في نعش علاقات متوتره
بين بريطانيا وايران توتر لم يكن وليد
اللحظه لكنه بدا منذ خمسينيات القرن
الماضي ولا يزال ففي عام
1953 شاركت بريطانيا الى جانب الولايات
المتحده في الاطاحه بحكومه محمد مصدق
واعاده الشاه محمد رضا بهلوي الى الحكم
وفي
1980 اغلقت بريطانيا سفارتها في طيران اما
في
اتهمت بريطانيا ايران بالتواصل مع الجيش
الجمهوري الايرلندي المحظور وفي يونيو
2009 جمدت بريطانيا وصول ايرانيه بموجب
عقوبات غربيه مفروضه بسبب برنامج ايران
النووي وفي 2011 فرضت بريطانيا عقوبات
ماليه على ايران وامرات جميع المؤسسات
الماليه البريطانيه بوقف التعامل مع
نظراتها الايرانيه والبنك المركزي
الايراني وفي اكتوبر 2022 فرضت بريطانيا
عقوبات على ثلاث شخصيات عسكريه ايرانيه
وشركه لتصنيع المواد الدفاعيه لتزويد
روسيا بطائره مسيره تستخدمها للضرب اهداف
في اوكرانيا وفي يناير
اعدم النظام الايراني المواطن البريطاني
الايراني علي رضا اكبر بتهمه التجسس
قضايا خلافيه وملفات شائكه توتر المتصاعد
على مر العقود لا يهدا تلك هي طبيعه
العلاقه التي تفرق ولا تجمع بين لندن
واتهران عصام عبد السلام العربيه